Ever seen one of these from years past
strike me down with all of your hatred
and your journey towards the
dark side will be complete
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new mandalorian season 2 video for grogu
in the darksaber there's a very important reason
why they have that scene they're foreshadowing a
lot of big things for later this season in the
finale but also the path that he's on for the
future seasons as well as well as what's happening
with the darksaber in future seasons is obviously
one of the most important items on the show if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we'll do a new giveaway
for disney plus memberships all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave all your
theories about the darksaber and grogu on the
video careful for spoilers for everything that
happened during the episode even though it was
one of the shortest episodes of the season they
still pushed the plot forward in a really big way
but the episode ends with moff gideon taunting
grogu in that scene with the darksaber asking
him if he remembers it from years past referencing
his time training on coruscant at the jedi temple
before the clone wars order 66 in the events
of the original trilogy of movies so not only
is it cool that grogu recognizes the darksaber
like he reaches out for it this also lets you
know that moff gideon knows more about grogu's
own history than the show has led on previously
giancarlo esposito did an interview kind of
hinting at grand admiral thrawn's connection to
all this saying that he had some sort of really
amazing information source feeding him all this
during the series here's the weird thing though
he doesn't refer to grogu by name even though he
probably does know his name he just calls him
the asset but i think that just feeds into the
idea that he only sees grogu as an asset in his
grand plans like he's not a person he's just an
object to be exploited this is kind of his default
mode of operation as we've seen is another way of
just baking a lot of darth vader references into
his villain character a lot of darth vader themes
vader never cared about any of his subordinates
or anyone around him they were just tools to be
used in pursuit of whatever his objectives were
in any given scenario most of the time when you
look at easter eggs and references like this
they're more for comedic value like all the
memes of darth vader choking his subordinates out
congratulations next guy you just got a promotion
that's why moff gideon pauses to stop his men
from saving the other stormtroopers from grogu
when he's using the force to just wreck them all
over the prison cell he even seems like he enjoys
all that violence coming off of him everyone post
all your emperor palpatine memes good do it let
the anger flow through you i've already mentioned
the obvious darth vader princess leia referenced
during this prison scene of him interrogating her
on the death star but the scene also takes a very
return of the jedi luke skywalker turned when
emperor palpatine was trying to turn luke to the
dark side by having him give in to his anger he
wanted luke to try and kill him knowing that by
doing so he would one fail because darth vader
was there to stop him and the emperor is super
powerful but even if he did fail it would be like
his anakin skywalker tuscan raider moment when
he went around killing all the tuscan raiders it
wouldn't immediately make him a sith but by giving
into his anger like that doing something so messed
up it makes them temporarily much more powerful
just giving in to that much emotion it makes it
kind of euphoric and it makes it much more likely
for them to react in a similar way the next time
they're faced with an impossible situation like
the next time a bunch of stormtroopers try to
force grogu to perform tests and take his blood
samples he's much more likely to give in to hate
and start tapping into the dark side of the force
instinctually to save himself but talking more
about the darksaber history and grogo's history
in the jedi temple even though he recognizes
the darksaber during the prequel era of movies
even though it was widely known it was widely
documented in most of the years leading up to the
phantom menace in the clone wars the blade mostly
rested with john favreau's pre-vizila character
he was the leader of the death watch mandalorians
from clone wars they were also featured during the
mandalorian season 1 episode 8 in that flashback
scene notice the symbols on their shoulders
that's the death watch crest they're the ones
that save mando that's why bo katan says you're
a child of the watch because they're referencing
the death watch mandalorians to be fair bo katan
was also a member of death watch for a little
while too just for a hot minute the reason why he
had it is because it was created by their family's
ancestor tarre vizsla over a thousand years ago he
was that first mandalorian to ever go to the jedi
temple and formally become a member of the jedi
he's the mandalore the great that they keep
referring to during season 1 when the armor
is talking about mandalore the great like bo katan
wants to name herself the new mandalore eventually
tar vizsla after he became a jedi and created
the darksaber came back to the planet mandalore
named himself mandalore and united all the
mandalorian clans there have been force sensitive
mandalorians before who just went untrained he
was just the first one to actually go through
jedi training formally may the force be with you
they sort of get into this when ahsoka tano is
talking to mando about grogu and the dangers of
the dark side during episode five there are many
many different force sensitive people in the
galaxy that just go untrained they never learn
about their abilities or their abilities are
so weak that they never really think about it
so when ahsoka tano is saying that it's safer
not to train grogu and let his powers wane
eventually if grogu were to go long enough without
using the force he'd just forget how to perform
the most common abilities he'll still always have
that same potential for power it's not like his
midichlorian count is going to change or anything
like that just get technical but it's just like a
skill that you have to learn if you go long enough
without practicing it you'll forget how to do it
so ahsoka tana was actually thinking about this
kind of scenario where moff gideon is able to take
advantage of grogu and manipulate him into turning
to the dark side like emperor palpatine did with
anakin skywalker pushing him to eventually become
darth vader grogo is a very big part of moff
gideon's plans for the galaxy and it goes beyond
just using him like a forced vampire he wants to
use his midichlorians in his cloning experiments
to make even stronger dark troopers but also he
would love to use grogu himself as another darth
vader style pawn just a really powerful dark side
force user potentially to execute his will around
the galaxy just another kind of super weapon for
him to roll out potentially in the future if he
were able to actually turn grogu to the dark side
i'll probably do more videos about this because
there's so much stuff that they're foreshadowing
grogo's storyline in this season and future
seasons as he gets more powerful in future
seasons it's going to get crazier and crazier i
think this part of the scene is also very clever
foreshadowing and setup for the season finale
in future seasons for a number of different
story lines not just grogu's storyline but
think about it this way look at those tiny
little hands on him while he's cuffed and grogo's
hands are so tiny themselves there's no way he'd
be able to wrap his hands around the hilt of the
darksaber even if he could take it from off gideon
but here's the other reason i think they showed
you grogo using the force to throw around the
stormtrooper so easily in a couple key scenes from
previous episodes of him using the force because
one of the more common jedi abilities especially
if you played any of the video games in the past
20 to 30 years is using the force to throw around
a lightsaber grogo actually doesn't need to hold
it in his hands to use it when he's not exhausted
like this he can just snatch it adam off gideon's
hands the way he was snatching the ball out of
mando's hand so now you see the importance of that
foreshadowing scene when they were testing his
abilities it's meant to show you what grogu can
do and foreshadow a bigger twist later on possibly
the season finale definitely future seasons
where moff gideon gets really overconfident like
he is here look at the smile on his face giancarlo
esposito is so good at doing evil guy scenes
like this so think of a scenario where he gets
super overconfident like this starts waving the
darksaber around and grogu who is not tired uses
the force to snatch it from his hands then throws
the darksaber around the room attacking moff
gideon and his men and the other really important
part of this scene here is when moff gideon says
possibly the most leading thing ever when he
says you're not ready to play with such things
you could take someone's eye out which means he's
probably totally going to take someone's eye out
with the darksaber also think about it this way
grogu spends most of his time stealing things
he snatches eggs all the time he snatches those
cookies all the time obviously it's hilarious
to watch him do that but it's also part of the
foreshadowing for eventual big twists in the
finale in future seasons like oh snatching things
stealing things just taking things that he wants
there's also a lot of foreshadowing for darker
grogu story arcs in future seasons but like they
say during mando and ahsoka tano scenes in episode
5 it's just one of many possibilities and a lot of
what ends up happening to grosgu the path that he
chooses to take as ahsoka says will be informed by
the people around him mando is like the good dad
influence like qui-gon jinn wanting to help anakin
skywalker when they found him obi-wan kenobi
hilariously didn't want to have anything to
do with anakin skywalker at first in moff gideon
being more like the bad dad like emperor palpatine
trying to create a negative father-son bond with
anakin in order to manipulate him but the other
side of this darksaber scene is meant to remind
you of the bokatan storyline that they teased
during episode 3 for the other mandalorians she's
on a mission not only to take that back but also
to kick the rest of the empire and moff gideon
off of mandalore the planet and name herself
the new mandalore taking everything back from
moff gideon and now we know grand admiral thrawn
that they've stolen from their people i also
realize everyone would love to see mando use
the darksaber at some point there's totally a
way they can do that and pay off the bo katan
darksaber storyline because i do think that bo
katan will ultimately be the one to take it back
and keep it but probably not to way later in the
series but post all your theories in the comments
below do you think that groku is going to be able
to take the dark saber at least for a little while
during the finale or future seasons i've got
a couple more videos about the jedi answering
grogu's call about boba fett and grogu in future
seasons so as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you should see those when they post
but leave all your video requests in the comments
congratulations joseph valente you're the giveaway
winner from my last big star wars video please
email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details everyone click
here for my full mandalorian season 2 episode
6 video and click here for my mandalorian grand
admiral thrawn video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!